حاله من الترقب تسود المنطقه المحيطه
بمنزل رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق
عمران خان بعد اشتباكات متقطعه بين انصاره
وقوات الامن فللمره الثانيه تفشل قوه
الامن في اعتقال عمران على خلفيه قضيه
فساد اثره تصدي انصاره لقوات الامن وتعليق
باجراءات اعتقاله مؤقتا بقرار قضائي فيما
الحكومه اتهمت عمران خان باستغلال انصاره
على عمران خان الا يتهرب من الامتثال
للقضاء والشرطه ويختبئ خلف مناصريه فهذا
القضاء نفسه الذي حكم لصالحه لا علاقه
للحكومه بعمل المحاكم والشرطه تنفذ ما
يطلبه منها القضاء
على مدى يومين حاولت قوه الامن تفريقه
الوزراء السابق اما ابرا خان دعى الى
الكفاح من اجل ما وصفه الحريه الحقيقيه
معتبرا ان مذكرات التوقيف ضده غير قانونيه
ومتهما للحكومه التي وصف اعضائها
بالمحتالين بمحاوله اختطافه او ربما قتله
لن يكون بامكان السيطره على الشباب عندما
يتعرضون لقمع قوات الامن فالاوضاع قد تخرج
عن السيطره اعلق املي على القضاء لقد سجلت
الحكومه ضد 80 بلاغا وقضيه والعدد يزداد
كل ذلك لحرمان من خوض الانتخابات كما اسال
المؤسسه العسكريه كان يهمها مصير البلاد
انصار عمران خان يعتبر انسحاب قوه الامن
من محيط منزله بمثابه انتصار له مرددينه
تافات مؤيده له ومنائه للحكومه ومحذرين من
مغبه اعتقاله
عمران خان هو املنا المتبقي للقضاء على
الفساد والظلم هو يحترم القانون وليست
المشكله في اعتقاله او تسليم نفسه لكن
المشكله ان حياته في خطر ونحن مستعدون
للتضحيه من اجله
عمران خان خط احمر ولن نسمح لحكومه
المستورده والفاسده باعتقاله او التعرض له
ورغما انسحاب قوات الامن وتعليق العمل
مؤقتا بمذكره اعتقاد عمران وقدح الطرق
المؤديه لمقر اقامته لا يزال المئات من
انصاره معتصمين بالقرب من منزله للتعبير
عن تضامنهم والتصدي لاي محاوله جديده
لاعتقال عمران
[موسيقى]
يحذر مراقبون من خروج الاوضاع عن السيطره
في وقت تعاني فيه بلاده اوضاعا امنيه
واقتصاديه صعبه عبد الرحمن مزين العربيه
لاهور